i want to say a big thank you to tropix
foods for giving one of the airports to
this
experiment guys you better add some
flavor in your life check out
tropics
okay guys so basically yesterday we had
a social experiment that we did
where we got atheists to put their self
in the shoes of theists
and give us the best argument for god so
today uh well the
the challenge was that whoever wins will
get airports right
so our first winner is george georgia
yeah how you doing
i'm doing great that's good georgia you
gave very good convincing arguments yeah
i was listening to i was going through
it um and i
found it really convincing so you said
that um on your way home
you fought some other ideas what was it
i was talking about human evolution and
how humans cannot evolve from
simple nuclear fusion between hydrogen
and helium how could flesh blood skin
bones everything be formed by just a
single atom it doesn't seem physically
possible as well as
thinking about the fact that there must
have been someone to put
everyone onto this earth like the sea
the plants the grass everything
and not have just appeared out of thin
air
i i have never heard the argument and
that is i think that's one of the best
arguments i've heard because i'm i
i i do i talk a lot of the atheists
agnostics that's what i do i'm a muslim
so i tell
i call people to islam basically give
them and that is i'm going to listen to
i'm going to research that you've
actually
you've educated me something today i
never saw it coming from that way
so that's you know that's the reason why
because usually it was the um
the normal airpods yeah these are the
airports pro yeah because of that
argument you deserve this airport pro
this is like
thank you so much how do you feel i feel
great it's okay this is amazing you
really deserved it because i didn't day
you know that argument in itself was
really good
now what i wanted to ask you further is
that um
as an atheist would you say you're still
an atheist or the arguments you proved
to us
oh you put you put yourself in our shoes
how's your stance on it now thinking
about it because you are
almost quite convincing did it not
convince you i mean in a way i still
believe in like obviously science
aspects i'm
quite a science yeah if you think about
it but like
i still believe in like science aspects
but you've also got like
famous scientists out there that have
believed in god so it is possible for
there to be some sort of superior being
that has
what i stand on to this earth that has
created what we stand on today
even charles darwin he believed in god
he was
yeah he was a christian so the thing is
what we're saying is we don't believe
as muslim we don't believe god to be a
man we don't believe
we believe he's he's free from the
creation he's not he's not in the
creation we don't believe he's a man
time is based yeah exactly so because we
believe there's nothing like him
so the thing is this concept that the
christians do believe jesus is god is a
man
but we believe that goes against his
very nature because god is unlimited how
could it be limited and come into
limited creation um i think so yeah one
of those yeah so the thing is
you're very articulate and intelligent
so i would say think about it because at
the end of the day like you
convinced us um with your argument
i think there is would you you would
agree that this whole universe cannot
come from nothing
yeah there has to be something that has
to be a cause as i've said
so yeah so what we say is that that
cause has to be god almighty
yeah yeah and um he wants a
relationship with you like for example
your mom and dad brought you to this age
right
um and imagine you turn around and say
no mom and dad
you did nothing for me and you totally
deny them yeah and even though you can
say yes but i can see my mum and dad i
can speak to them yeah but there are
things
elements that we have in our life that
we can't see like for example gravity is
something we can't see we see the
effects of
dark matter is something we cannot
observe but we see the effects of um so
has it convinced you to to a point where
you would say you know i would i would
want to look a bit more deep into it and
maybe question my
opinions as an atheist i have looked
into it because i have had i do have
um muslim friends i do have uh christian
friends
and they've all i've always like kind of
been pushed towards
islam more only because of like there's
actually physical existing things for
example like the kaaba
and you have like the quran as well that
has never been translated because it
doesn't want to be translated wrong
for example like the bible obviously i'm
not being anything against them
but the bible has been translated in
certain wrong ways which has portrayed
them
to like it's been corrupted yeah yeah
whereas like with the quran
it's never been translated out of arabic
yeah it's been it's been preserved in
its original form
yeah so that's that's that's good and i
hope that you can look into it further
i was going to give you a quran i don't
know if you haven't do you have quran
i didn't have okay if you want i can get
you one um or if
if you have the time try to get one and
read it for yourself uh
yeah so thank you for your time thanks
for taking part in it and um
as well as you your argument is very
convincing it has had some effect on you
and hopefully you know one day we might
see in the park as a muslim maybe
maybe maybe enjoy the airports and thank
you for your time
thank you thank you sister georgia thank
you very much thank you so very good
uh it was one of the good ones the first
place was a girl called
uh was her name georgie i think her name
was georgio yeah but you guys still
want something airport do you want it um
so
firstly before i give that to you you
guys put yourself in our shoe yes your
arguments were quite convincing
did it make you think for a second hold
on a second actually you know
maybe there is something here maybe like
did you change your perception like as
atheist
did you do yeah definitely definitely
obviously
you put you made us put in your shoes
and we had to think about it it's like
going back to school in rv
so yeah we have to think about
everything so yeah kind of change your
point of view yeah
yeah so okay so the argument for like
because because you you brought some
arguments i can't really remember
specifically what it was um but you're
saying that for example all of this
coming from nothing et cetera
so would you still like would you say
you're still
atheist or would you say you're i'm not
going to say drastic change of belief
here
but would you say that you're more
agnostic you can be honest you know
more knowledgeable you made us think
about it more thinking about it if you
think
yeah yeah more logical yeah you don't
can't really love your life you know
what i mean
so so you would you would believe that
the universe didn't come from nothing
there must be of course okay that's good
um any any other did you have because we
had one georgia she was like on the way
back home
she was thinking of more arguments like
she could have made for the theater's
position
um did you have any other like as he was
going on was he thinking like you know
actually i couldn't make a
better case or was it just like i think
what i
said yesterday about the seed and how
everything's very perfect positioned
um i've always stood by that and that's
why i always been my argument so okay so
are you an atheist i would say you
agnostic i
i don't know it there's so many some
things you said you're like
that doesn't make sense maybe someone
could have created that or
then some things like that you know how
another thing is like i don't understand
is how
our some of our dna is uh linked with
like cabbages and bananas yeah bananas
very strange like some things i'm like
that's not right
even the whole dna thing though but if
you think about like the whole dna the
way it's structured
it's like it's actually like it's like a
little factory you know and like the way
how you look how i look how you look um
and like if we if if we look at like a
program be a computer
that's got like you know um you know
it's got it's got algorithms and the way
it's structured you know
and the dna is more complex than all of
them
do we wouldn't yesterday everything's
perfect so if there's one thing wrong
how can you make something wrong because
everything is perfect yeah yeah
there must be something there yeah yeah
yeah definitely
it's crazy okay i'm not gonna hold you
guys longer so you won the airport
these ones yeah um i thank you for
taking part i don't know how you're
gonna divide that
or sell it and share the money i don't
know i'll give one airport to him you
carry the other one
yeah no problem thank you very much for
your time it was it was just thought
provoking
and we learned from each other um yeah
that's it any last words
thank you very much thank you very much
thank you thank you for coming and guys
hope you enjoyed it if you want part two
we can try part two let us know okay
guys so basically we had
three people who were gonna win the
airports yeah okay
we had the first uh winner was georgia
and then second uh was toby
and lauren and third was a girl called
rachel uh but was still
the message on instagram was waiting for
us to get back to us but
we had someone what was your name idon
iden
yes that's that's actually that's a
turkish name
it is here yeah okay so i didn't we
we admired his effort because i saw your
effort and i said okay you know what
let's not leave it empty-handed
um so the brother's going to get that
but in the meantime what i wanted to do
was
when he goes and gets him i'm going to
give you that is your arguments were um
good was you self-convinced
actually yeah like the things you told
me yesterday i actually thought about
them while coming here
and they actually really made sense
because like personally
i'm an atheist and are you still an
atheist
well i'm not sure here but the points he
made were really convincing to me
like how i had to like convince you um
what was it um yeah like you're saying
that for example
it cannot come from nothing yeah and
then
yeah like the points really made sense
so
even though he didn't win the airport
yeah but when i watched the video and
your argument for the proof of god
was good and i thought it's for my own
money yeah and i thought you know what
the effort counts
so there's a 50 squeezy let's show it to
the british the queen's you see the
queen is there guys
put respect on the queen hold it yes
like this as you can see
50 pounds what do they call this on the
roads
a little pinky yeah okay all right it's
a little pinky
so there you go enjoy it i don't know
what you're going to do with it yeah
um hopefully not drugs it may not be
drugs
i'm joking tell me any any last words um
thank you for this no problem thank you
we're gonna do another one maybe with a
iphone all right yeah maybe come again
and we can
yeah thank you toby have a nice day and
say bye bye to your friend the polar
bear
take care all right guys so yesterday we
had a social experiment where we asked
atheists to put their sh put their self
in a fierce position and give us the
best argument for god
so we had uh georgia who came a young
lady who once she gave good examples
and then we had toby and lauren who came
they won the airport uh they came second
place
um and we had rachel we're going to
contact rachel where we try to
she hasn't got back to us yet but she
wins the last airpods which is the
airport
airport's pro so yeah if she comes we're
going to give that and this young man he
gave good effort so before we give him a
little 50 pounds let him enjoy it
because if it was there
and we're gonna wait for rachel to come
and that's it i hope you enjoyed it if
you want part two
of the social experiment comment in the
section below